Over the last five decades,
the Brazilian economy has been on a virtual roller coaster.
[Inaudible].
Periods of strong economic growth and high expectations have been followed by
crises, devaluations and even hyperinflation.
This is what happened in the late 1980s, for example, in 1918, 19,
the Brazil experienced 1320% inflation.
And in 1990 2740%.
Yeah.
Is that 50 years after experiencing what became known as the Brazilian miracle,
Brazil has still not managed to take the leap forward.
It needs to become a developed country. Still over the past few decades,
Brazil has attracted investment for many companies and in many financial
circles,
it has come to be considered one of the great hopes among American economies.
[Inaudible].
Have you ever heard of the bricks? I'm sure you have.
So why have we chosen to talk about Brazil and this new collaboration with value
school?
Well.
We have done this firstly,
to find out when and why the Brazilian economy became so popular. And secondly,
because we want to answer three key questions. Firstly,
can stock markets help small investors protect themselves from periods of crisis
political upheaval and the processes of high inflation and even hyperinflation
that are so common in many American countries.
[Inaudible].
Secondly, what does the case of Brazil tell us about all that?
Yes.
Can the case of Brazil teaches anything about how to best apply the processes of
economic reform? We will try to answer all these questions, but first,
the first thing we have to do is find out where the story begins,
the origin of this particular rollercoaster that we see today before we get
started, though,
I just wanted to remind you about our new channel visual Academy.
It covers all the most interesting people, places and periods in history.
Do you want to know more about gangs Cannes or the ancient Greeks,
or maybe even the Vikings? Of course you do lose our cool teams in history.
So check them out with amazing animations, fantastic stories,
and a voiceover from someone you might recognize checkout visual Academy here on
YouTube. Uh, no, let's go.
Brazil's economic miracle.
Period from the end of the 1960s to the end of the 1970s has come to be known as
Brazil's economic miracle. Although, as we will see,
it was not really a miracle at time.
All.
You're talking about a complex difficult period,
a period marked by a military dictatorship,
repression and persecution of any political and social movement that was not
properly aligned with military bodies and poets.
Hello.
In spite of everything during those years,
the economy also registered enormous economic growth.
These are known as the years have led to give you an idea in 19 eight Brazil's
GDP was growing at 9.8%. And by 1973,
this group reaching an astonishing 14%,
however,
beyond the economic growth that the country registered during the first years of
the dictatorship, the truth is that the basis for this growth are not the best.
The military government stimulated,
the arrival of foreign capital and measures were implemented to protect
financial investments,
but they also bet on stimulating internal demand through the execution of large
infrastructure works.
We are talking about projects such as the EDP mega hydroelectric plant,
the trauma Amazonian highway and the Angora nuclear power plant,
all financed with public money and debt. What's more in 1964,
the military created the central bank of Brazil,
which they did not hesitate in using to finance their enormous public works
projects.
As a result during the military rain Brazil's foreign debt multiplied by 30 and
inflation grew and exceeded 34% in 1974.
So when the first oil crisis broke out in 1973,
crude oil quadrupled in price at the exact same time,
the international credit became scarce.
That's when the Brazilian economy began to have problems in just two years,
GDP growth was reduced by 10 points. Despite this,
the military government decided to continue with its huge public spending plans
to try and boost the economy
and that that only made the economy even more vulnerable. So in 1979,
when a new oil crisis full of the Iranian revolution,
Brazil's economy faced another severe blow
economic growth, practically disappeared.
It's simply vanished and come from rural materials plummeted.
The foreign debt had to be renegotiated to ever higher and higher interest
rates.
And the government accounts no longer added up either above or below the lane,
not on one site nor on the other,
the Brazilian economy was headed for disaster.
That pretty much described exactly what happened,
unable to resort to foreign credit and with a growing imbalance in public
accounts, the government turned to the central bank for financing.
My friends that was the beginning of the end
inflation soon exceeded 100% per year and various attempts to stabilize the
situation did not work. And the end,
the economic crisis itself led to the fall of the military government in 1985.
Of course the advent of democracy did not bring prosperity either. In 1987,
the Brazilian government suspended their loan payments and between 1989 and
1993, the country practically lived under constant hyperinflation.
Check this out.
When I was 10 year old in the 1980s in Brazil,
my job was to run through the supermarket aisles to pass adults who aren't with
the labeling machines. So large that they made us laugh,
wandered around the place raising prices throughout the day.
Rodrigo side-on professor of economics and finance.
At the New York university in Shanghai.
At the same time during the first three years of the 1990s,
the GDP per capita plummeted by 10%.
And so we arrived at 1994 the year in which was perhaps being the most
ambitious plan for reform in Brazil's history.
Was launched the real plan.
The real blend initiated by Fernando Henrico Cardoso first as minister of
finance and later as president of Brazil aims to go much further.
Cardoso.
His plan sought to completely transform the reality of the Brazilian economy by
means of the privatization of the public sector,
financial system reforms attracting foreign investment and the opening up of the
Brazilian economy to the world through mercury, sir.
But the first task was undoubtedly to contain the wild hyperinflation.
The country was suffering
And an attempt to achieve price stability.
The government launched a rapid action program that aims to end the budget tree
and balance and the public accounts.
And immediately afterwards established a new monetary standard,
the real value unit,
the value of which was linked to the U S dollar and which was assigned affects
daily rate and the central bank,
little by little wages rates and prices recorded using this new value unit.
And finally, on the 1st of June, 1994,
the real value unit became the new currency of Brazil commonly referred to as
the reality. You know,
what the effects on inflation were immediate?
Well during the first two financial quarters of 1994 inflation registered,
or an average increase of weight for it,
more than 40% per month after the introduction of the reality,
this was reduced to just over 3% during the second half of the year,
inflation gradually declined until 1998.
When it registered an annual increase of only 2.6%, take a look.
So.
First objective achieved.
The next goal was to restructure and recapitalize the entire financial system,
an operation that was led by the state itself through poor the program to
stimulate the restructuring and strengthening of the national financial system.
This was a program where the government intervened and financial entities that
presented problems. These entities were then given credit facilities.
The state bought the unpaid loans they had on their balance sheets,
and finally sold the entities in many cases to large international banking
groups
Between 1994 and July and December in 1998,
76 banks were liquidated or transparent.
It was at precisely this time that both Banco Santander and then BBV
[inaudible] entered Brazil through the purchase of Brazilian banks that had been
the objects of the government intervention so far. So good.
The fact is that after inflation was brought under control and the financial
restructuring and privatization programs of public enterprises have begun local
conditions in the eyes of international investors, improved significantly,
suddenly Brazil became fashionable and foreign capital began to pour into the
country. For example, Telefonica,
a Spanish operator is the largest operator in Brazil today entered the country
in 1998 with the purchase of the public company.
Tell step to give you an idea of the scale of this move.
It is estimated that between 1993 and 1998,
the Brazilian government raised a total of 68 billion from the sale of public
companies. That's billion dollars with a B. Well,
at that time, everything seems to be going smoothly. However, the truth was,
and the Brazilian roller coaster students started up again, the question is,
would things turn out differently for Brazil this time to find it,
listen up.
All paths lead to here.
Everything seemed to be going smoothly and at full speed, however,
little by little things go on, more complicated.
And the first place the plan had the initial objective of improving public
accounts. But what happened was actually the opposite.
The new social commitments brought about by democracy,
the growing weight of the pension system and financial restructuring,
all triggered public debt. To give you an idea,
the financial reform alone cost the public coffers around $100 billion.
[Inaudible].
Not only that since one of the government's objectives to boost economic growth
was to attract foreign capital.
It maintained the policy of very high interest rates,
which greatly increased the cost of that public debt.
This in turn forced the state to SU large amounts of debt in order to finance
itself.
Thus.
An only four years between 1994 and 1998,
the Brazilian public debt increased threefold or the public deficit claims to
7.4% of the fixed GDP.
And this.
This leads us directly to the second problem.
The combination of high interest rates with huge issuances of public debt
greeted what is known as crowding out a massive.
The savings.
Resilience and the huge influx of foreign capital were mainly directed to the
purchase of public debt after all.
Why take risks with other investments when you can simply buy government debt
and get a huge return.
This.
Crowding out phenomenon was so great,
but despite the enormous amount of capital Brazil received from the rest of the
world, companies found it increasingly difficult to obtain credit.
And not only that many of the countries,
large companies began to direct the resources towards the purchase of public
debt to at that time buying government securities was more profitable than
reinvesting in their own businesses.
This may seem incredible.
But to a large extent, this is what explains why between 1993 and 2003,
the rate of return for the 500 largest Brazilian companies was to increase by
80% while their investment only increased by 3.8% per year.
The search for easy and apparently secure rents drove capital,
not towards new investment projects,
but basically towards the purchase of public debt,
a textbook case of what is known in economics as the crowding out effect
And the end,
the opening up to the outside world together with a lack of concrete measures to
boost the competitiveness of local only added to this crowding out effect and an
exchange rate.
And flitted by a policy of high interest rates caused the bank account balance
to reverse and enter negative territory.
The result was that foreign debt began to grow again.
And then.
Along came 1998,
the year of both the Russian crisis and the Asian crisis.
These crises made foreign capital begin to flow out of the emerging economies at
Phillips 1999.
The Brazilian economy had to be rescued the IMF together with the world bank,
the Inter-American development bank,
and several countries that offered to be part of the rescue group had to put in
more than $40 billion on the table,
Even.
So when the central bank of Brazil was forced to let their Brazilian rail flow
freely, the currency lost more than 60% of its fine.
[Inaudible].
The rollercoaster was ruling again.
That was until the next commodity boom between 2000 and 2014.
And soon after another huge crisis from which the country has still not
recovered. The Brazilian economy has really had its ups and downs,
But at this point, I'm sure many of you were thinking, well, grant,
if this video was made in collaboration with value school,
you must be about to tell us what happened with the stock market.
So just what on earth did happen to the financial markets during this time?
Well,
the truth is the Brazilian stock market followed practically the same steps as
the national economy and especially those of foreign capital flows into the.
[Inaudible].
As you can see in this graph.
And just two and a half years between the beginning of 1995 and the middle of
1997, the BOVESPA index of the Brazilian stock market increased by a factor.
Okay.
Three.
In any case, the most surprising fact is that during the last 50 years,
and in spite of all the ups and downs crises,
and hyperinflations that Brazil has experienced the Brazilian stock market has
reached a real return that is corrected for inflation of 6.7%
to illustrate this better.
Let's take the case of two hypothetical investors who in 1968,
we've invested the equivalent of 100 RIAs and today's money.
Let's say the first investor invested has money and bank deposits. Well,
the second invested in exchange traded fund or ETF index to Bovis BOVESPA well,
the D the first one would have absolutely nothing. Well,
the second one would have investments worth $2,573,
I guess that proves the power of equities and shorts.
This is the story of how Brazil became fashionable,
how it defeated hyperinflation and how the roller coaster returned.
In spite of everything with this story,
we wanted to put two ideas on the table.
The first is that you have to be very careful with trends and with reform
processes. They are not always the panacea this into B.
If they are not well mapped out, the results can be very disappointing.
The second is that despite everything investing in equities was the best way for
Brazilians to protect their long-term savings.
Now, you understand.
Better why the mission of our friends over at value school is precisely to
promote financial culture. So we really hope you've enjoyed this video.
Please hit the Lake if you did.
And don't forget to subscribe for brand new videos.
Don't forget to check out our friends at the reconsider media podcast to live
provided the vocals and this episode, we're not my dulcet tones. Also,
this channel is possible because of Patrion and our cane patrons on that
platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage. And as always, I'll see you next time.
And if you want to learn more about politics and hear even more of my lovely
voice, you can join us at reconsider media.
We have a podcast@reconsidermedia.com slash podcast. See you there.